this is the official one-piece merch
store here in shibuya and today i'm on a
mission to find the best and worst
one-piece merch out there down in the
busy streets of shibuya we finally catch
a glimpse of our quarry a scared anime
youtuber possibly a male desperately
trying to reach the safety of the one
piece store a seemingly endless maze of
shops restaurants and galleries it is
one of the most densely visited parts of
tokyo and so i found it to be the best
place for my mission but i thought that
starting with the most obvious place
would be sort of cheating for this
challenge i wanted to find everything
one piece shibuya had to offer however
you have to be careful not to get lost
or even worse run into some pretty
suspicious looking company this is my
friend sarah and
even though she doesn't have anything to
do with one piece or most anime in
general
she knows who wears somano always gets
lost when going around so i'm going to
help him in shibuya today let's go
shopping
now even though i really love anime i
somehow never was too much into
merchandise but somehow anime is now not
only one of my biggest passions but for
some strange but really awesome reasons
also my full-time job now and living in
tokyo the mecca of any anime lover i was
finally ready to jump into the cold
water and see for the first time if i
have been wrong or rights little did i
know that i would be spending over 600
on merchandise before the day was over
fighting our way through the crowd and
several tiny alleyways with sarah's help
i made it to our first location animate
and i was absolutely convinced that this
was gonna be the perfect starting point
to find some great one-piece stuff the
warm air in the store was heavy with the
smell of books plastic and people
aimlessly making my way through rows and
rows of books and items i did stumble
across some interesting things some very
interesting things wait this is this
corner will get demonetized here except
for what we had come for animate is one
of the biggest anime merch stores in
japan as far as i know no one piece so i
am a bit confused i gotta say then at
last in a small glass cabinet in one of
the corners i finally spotted what i had
been looking they have one piece perfume
what
nami very sexy smell luffy
it smells like a freedom and adventure
one i kind of do want to smell like zoro
texture it's pretty good any other words
other than good isn't that also
effective it's very sexy as well it's
like i like i like both of them like if
i had to name that fragrance i would
call it uh samurai in the woods but
sold out next store next door so yeah in
the end i couldn't even get the one
thing i really wanted from the store so
now he's smelling all of them
it doesn't smell too good right now by
the way guys you don't know that but i
do some of them are really nice and some
of them are really weird
[Music]
despite his best efforts he was not able
to complete his quest
an utter disappointment but he is not
ready to give up yet
what do they have they have a lot like
what let's go find out
[Music]
even though to me it looked like just a
regular very modern department store
pretty much the opposite of the store
before when we left the elevator on the
sixth floor it felt like we had entered
a version of japan that my 15 year old
self might have come up with sorry i'm
meant to be guiding you but you're
guiding me that's a cool sword
in the middle of this enormous space i
was greeted by the official nintendo
store and right next to it was a capcom
store featuring classics like monster
hunter and street fighter and behind it
the official pokemon center i think for
five minutes or so i completely forgot
what i had come here for and just let
myself be swept away in fond childhood
memories oh also there was this awesome
store
japan
where were we oh yeah we were looking
for the best and worst one-piece
merchandise and right there it was the
official jump store
[Music]
there's your boy
i have a question another one
today
but first now as you've heard earlier my
japanese is far from being perfect but
simply being able to understand and talk
to people and hear their stories has
been one of the best things since coming
back to japan so if you are also
interested in starting to learn japanese
today's sponsor might be just the right
thing for you rosetta stone is one of
the most popular tools for language
learning with a ton of different
languages and more than 250 hours of
immersive content they make sure to
teach you words that native speakers
actually use and help you to study as
efficiently as possible so if you've
been planning to learn japanese go check
out my link in the description below to
get a great discount on all monthly
subscriptions or better yet there is a
lifetime subscription option as well so
you can pay only once and get access to
over 20 different languages okay so the
moment i stepped into the jump store
surrounded by the first one-piece
opening and luffy cheering me on i was
convinced this had to go better than the
first time that's actually a really cool
bag and indeed my first find were these
awesome stickers by a company called
b-side label that i absolutely love i
went with this legendary one of kizuru
just because he now is my most watched
one-piece character analysis on the chip
zorro mug
this is actually pretty cool
is that calendar oh yeah this isn't one
piece it's not one piece it's don't yeah
no i never looked at this you're
cheating on one i never i never did that
now the lamest thing i could find was
this thing here is it a finger sock and
let's just say my opinion on this has
changed drastically since that moment
but let's count it as fast stop doing
dirty things it's not dirty it's chopper
yo
look like you fingered it
my favorite item i got in the store
however was this i'm really sorry but
i have to get this it's not one piece
but i mean it's a raw version of the
manga panel
i do feel ashamed though also when i
went to pay the guy asked me if i wanted
this golden comedy thing here i thought
it was free but it wasn't well played
sir let's see what's inside
it is more silver wrapping paper
asmr with manu
what the [ __ ] what is this
i can't believe he tricked me into
buying this we haven't watched golden
calm weights awesome okay so we did get
some nice stuff and i also got some dumb
stuff but i think you'll agree that this
was still far from being the best or
worst one-piece merch i could possibly
imagine hours have passed and still
o'hara has been unable to locate the
right piece of merchandise should he not
be successful soon the stalls will close
also just quick notice it's dark
we literally spent the entire when you
wake up here at 11 10 i don't know it's
done
we have been looking at a lot of one
piece stuff and then we finally made our
way to the place that i had been most
excited to go to the official one-piece
store right next to the world famous
shibuya crossing that now was buzzing
with even more people streaming towards
the tempting smell of the many
restaurants around however we were not
here for fun we were here for epic one
piece merchandise which may sound like
fun i'll give you that but we have been
added for hours at this point but i'm
not heartless enough a friend to let my
brave guide and camera woman starve to
death it smells so good i want to crave
this looks great i eat sausages and
crepes and it's pizza what's the sugar
baby i'm a plain girl you like sugar too
he's german
did they go to the wrong country i did
i'm a stupid guy all right
as he gets more and more desperate to
find what he's looking for he tries to
replenish his energy by foraging for
what keeps him alive
new subscribers by the way guys this
video took a lot of time and a lot of
money to make so if you enjoy this type
of content make sure to hit the secret
red button
on the way up to the 6-4 i surprisingly
stumbled across this little store here
that had a one-piece collaboration going
on look at that shanks jacket i swear i
was so close to buying that but in the
end decided that i was not quite brave
enough to pull that look off in public
and i guess you can imagine that this
jacket was expensive as finally after a
long journey he has found what he came
for
sadly enough the one-piece door only
permits photography no filming here we
go let's get rolling let's get right
into it okay first of all i loved all
the apparel they had especially this
sweater with crocodile as well as this
soccer kit that was a special
collaboration with fc tokyo the first
item i got was this awesome
upside down cover page of zorro and
sanji because i mean look at it it's
perfect i also found some pretty bad
items as well which honestly made me
pretty happy this diving cover and this
fan right here are pretty lame and i
ended up buying this again that changes
sabo's head whenever you press it i've
been doing this for the past few hours a
ton of plushies of course look how cute
they are i didn't get one though i'm a
grown-up just kidding i got this super
awesome doe flamingo cat that's now in
charge of smirking at me when i'm not
doing my work
[Music]
definitely part of the best merge for me
now going back to the worst i also got
this sexy zorro writing block
as well as this robin boop keychain that
is meant to work as a stress ball i
swear i haven't been using it i also got
this zorro nail clipper
as if i hadn't spent enough money yet
however i also purchased this mystery
item for 300 bucks that will be custom
delivered be ready for a super big
unboxing video on that i really want to
tell you now i can't tell you how
excited i am for this probably my
favorite piece of merch i bought i found
this epic collaboration between one
piece and new era i mean how awesome are
these i ended up with this one because
i'm a real sucker for black on black now
the funniest thing is that i went to pay
i had spent so much money that i ended
up finishing nine out of the ten point
cards for the store which got me these
super awesome wanted posters as well as
these super lame plastic bags okay so i
think this was a real success we got so
many awesome and shitty things and i
really have to apologize to everyone
who's into merch if you want to know why
my favorite character zorro check out
that video right here